all right welcome back to part 29 yeah
you're probably hearing some background
noise it's because I'm on a Skype call
with a friend of mine and he insisted
that is but we were gonna do this cuz I
didn't I really didn't want to play this
game why don't you say hello oh [ __ ]
I think I just heard him
I heard the monster
aigis uh oh [ __ ] there is cesium Oh
Hollister Alice are you kidding me
that's gonna kill all I don't know
should be following me
never mind to it I can't tell yet the
smart demos dude I don't think they can
understand the switch it doesn't matter
it's just me
I was like him in all honesty no I'm
talking for the viewers always get it
caught over here oh [ __ ]
oh my gosh
oh no no no tell me how incoming I don't
have played this game but I continue are
you done
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Mike oh don't look at
him oh look at him don't look at him if
you look at him for too long many will
find you eventually this is still there
oh this was a bad idea I told you no
very good idea oh [ __ ] there is strut
that ass strut that ass I thought I
could run in bearing it and it damaged
me [ __ ] that how could you throw
something at it
no there's nothing to throw a car that
would be nice
there's no way to kill them see I'm
afraid of the light
I'm guessing I don't put the spare their
base you haven't seen this part so
basically what's going on is that we met
the guy down here in the elevator
we took an elevator down in the castle
and the guy we were gonna kill at
Alexander he's behind that wall but we
can get in there unless we have the
sphere so we're gonna collect different
parts and then place them there that's
what I think it is at least [ __ ] what an
[ __ ] I'm guessing we're gonna go in
there where he went
[ __ ]
that was horrible
Oh
and notes do you want to read it alright
I guess I can take that as a No
the shattered orb all is lost I must
once again start over
ever since I recovered the orb first
found by Agrippa yeah a great place the
guy we just talked to I have depended on
it for my research the incident with
villa ham made me most impetuous varying
a paucity of prisoners I proceed with
the final ritual without proper
foresight the orb cracked and fell into
six part yeah this is what I talked
about earlier we got to collect all the
parts I've tried everything but have yet
to mend the thing unless I can think of
a way to piece it together I will have
to find another there's still life in
pieces and even if the orb isn't
restored I might be able to salvage some
of his power for some other purpose
centuries have passed in vain and I
begin to wonder if I will ever be able
to see my love again how much longer can
I sustain in my life I think Alexander
wrote that I'm pretty sure basically the
guy I called Agrippa had an award is and
that's what the monster is like guarding
and we had an Orbis well but it gets
stolen by the guy we're gonna kill and
I'm guessing the reason why the guy went
on the kill wanted the orb was to revive
his loved work something I don't know
nice
same [ __ ] statues everywhere could G
produce its mustard yeah I probably
could but probably wouldn't do much
maybe this yeah Oh elleven in the lane
Oh Robert yeah I will okay I don't think
there's anything in there Oh
a ritual with hell
some oil I like when it's lit up lighten
up or whatever
but there is nothing in here
except scared of stuff
uh-huh
so that was it
okay I'm not gonna go there Felix where
is to see her I don't know we're gonna
collect the parts and they're supposed
to be wait I guess I could show you like
how many porch do I have zero oh oh [ __ ]
I thought that oh never mind let's go in
here
but I think I'm pretty close to finish
the game actually and that makes me
happy yeah me too
all right another no it's got them it no
I tried to study the different tools in
the tool Kent they're in this right and
learn how to use they can hear that last
time was messy the effects oh [ __ ]
No
uh-huh where did it go ritual No
ah annoying it's got to be that fishing
huh
ah whatever produce not something
important ah I think we found something
bucket of tar
and we find a tinderbox if I can just
yeah
oh [ __ ] I thought I heard something so
we'll let it sit in your books I don't
know you just liked up the lamps with
them
sounds like machinery over here that is
and I can't go in there
what do you think I'm going to use with
a bottle of top bucket of tar stick
guitar yeah
I guess there's nothing here after all
it's pretty damn creepy down here though
what the [ __ ] built this
isn't tore like boys be pumped yeah
scary parts scary part you sent me that
letter asking for Helen I'm vixx's how
to repay me how dare you can I go out
here one touch you know what budge means
budge oh [ __ ]
everything went red what the hell what
does that mean never good news what did
you ask budge
ya won't move ah affair began to drown
him again he reached once more for the
empty bottle of latinum in frustration
he smashed it against the bedpost
I think you collect the parts down here
actually
if these cells are mental prisoners who
are under treatment the people you send
war will
remember that the confinement itself
works as a preamble to the torture and
he's yourself
understood sounds from the torture
chambers are shuttled in through those
heights in the sea
manage your victims well
one of small payments to Tara [ __ ] was I
what does the white like me a white
light yeah which white light I can see
white light spreading up on this screen
sometimes I think that's just my desktop
background or something
oh hey die oh oh oh oh
not going in there oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is going up huh okay I'm going to show
you a gripper this is kind of
interesting
what you
I know it's ridiculous
I mean are you watching but if you put
anything that's turning a black bag near
your heart I would you
ringing - it's turning off it's a nice
working motivated I can't have asked you
for some sort of koshish time to be
princess huh
this it's a boat oh wow
can't get up a whuppin climbing it does
he look nice who's that
that's Agrippa is that something you did
no aleksander problem and it's his orbit
that we're gonna collect the parts of I
think you are Alexander you think yeah
I'm pretty sure I'm not actually
miss Daniel that's me oh [ __ ] I got this
scared for what
what is this blue nope
I hate when I don't know where I should
go it's annoying just empty prison cells
everywhere and it's scary empty prison
cells huh
me I'll wait down chicks
tinderbox
thank you
sorry hints
Oh God so many stuff
yeah I know that you know that yeah I
know that